paper is his passion
whether he's making people birds or
armadillos the origami artists e pool
mbona is a true master of the art of
Japanese paper folding home sets of last
weekend I was attracted by the idea that
it's possible to make anything you want
from a square piece of paper smooth edge
that then cut this is where his
creations are born in a small studio in
lucerne he draws cuts and folds as he's
been doing most of his life venice nice
with chickens in gun if i remember
rightly I was about five years old when
my mother taught me how to fold a paper
plane up here fingers bhagava I loved it
from the very beginning the iphone and
from that point onwards i flew tons of
paper planes into my neighbor's garden
dun dun mais pas PFE england god man
enough punishment
but now he's working on a whole
different scale in the building of a
former radio station which is now used
as an exhibition hall cpool mbona is
trying to fold a life-size elephant from
a piece of paper 15 by 15 meters the
paper has been specially made and
imported from America paid for by
donations collected online skip down
your youth balloon and get down let's
cut it good you start thinking there are
no limits to what you can make from a
square of paper as a monk on in there
Bruce and Scott India hits arbor when
you do this kind of large-scale work the
thickness of the paper means you're
dealing with different physical forces
in fur hat is to pop here they go so the
whole process is different they can
support esken's illness mbona and his
friends have already been working on the
elephant for two weeks this giant sheet
of paper cost thirteen thousand dollars
with an area of 225 square meters and a
weight of 100 kilos it's hard to handle
and it's not yet clear if the
construction will work because there is
no template all the artist has to guide
him are some geometric sketches contesta
human you believe me awaken kappa to
consider which part of the animal's body
i want to have we're on the paper the
tears were from Papa Hamlet as much
money for example if I have a square and
I think to myself up or key ok I want to
put the elephant's tail here the two
legs here on the side he hadn't kept a
body could be here in between the trunk
in the ears yeah and you won so far so
good seipel mbona has made an
international name for himself with his
origami art it's been used in this
commercial for a Japanese an athletic
shoe manufacturer I founded a sport shoe
company when you took a tiger
he designed a living area for an
advertising agency in Hamburg and he
folded koi fish for a singapore hotel
cpool mbona receives commissions from
all over the world because his work is
truly unique fish tell anna marie de
festa said he comes from simple mobile
like we see you again and again how
fascinated our visitors are by sifu
mamonas art on the one hand because
they're fascinated at how he can make
such different things from a single
piece of paper yet he hand on the other
hand because he really is pushing the
boundaries of origami the third on the
greenhouse to jesus said he's a
technique Jesus all he call me Pete his
elephant is a case in point SI può mbona
and his helpers try to stand up the
elephant but the paper pachyderm isn't
quite ready as this Corinne was him the
problem we're facing at the moment is an
imbalance between the size and the
stability of the paper through Horace
and that means the folds don't hold like
they should we have to find another
solution one could be the use of
wallpaper paste to reinforce the paper
or a construction to support the paper
elephant the one option C pool mbona is
not willing to consider is giving up he
won't rest until his paper elephant can
stand on its own four legs besides he's
received a request to make another
elephantine elephant this time from
South Africa
Oh